ah welcome sorry
welcome to three free experts today
we're gonna play the best games on free
games ever made remember that spec wait
remember that really gate remember that
one really really gay game we played
well here's another one from the same
creator succulent a deep game by Robert
yang okay
I am lost for words is that Justin
Bieber right all the songs
she's so [ __ ] trippy I don't even
[ __ ] know what's going on okay I
don't even
ah [ __ ] is he doing the [ __ ] it's going
on isn't all the horror games were not
bad enough don't do that please
okay alright it's it's been great happy
for you guys happy about that thing that
we did and totally time you brothers are
like you should play better games and
then you suggest me this hey I love this
game this is my favorite game like don't
I'm not hitting
there's poop there used to be a saying
back into my school we used to say look
there's a [ __ ] hole again that's what
people said to me
alright toilet time it's a game about
pooping it what is start you can't just
[ __ ] what it clown I got the clown do
I win no I get to see a pair of legs
okay adjust one hotter you want colder
with the [ __ ] you won oh how I how I
grandpa the search engine erase all
right this is like dumb ways to die this
is literally dumb ways to diiie 30
supposed to play this on the toilet am i
doing it wrong hold oh okay that you
it's funny it's [ __ ] hilarious find
what find what what I do
dammit yeah I don't know you were gonna
take a [ __ ] swipe Oh No me being me so
that's my French all right well this is
try it again
find what find vacuum Oh a vacant how
English how does it work why doesn't
grandpa have nipples what the yeah oh
god what's Oh No
thing went better than expected what the
[ __ ] way what is this Oh Kim Kim Kim
can I please late play toilet time
without you [ __ ] coming into my house
do I come to your wedding and take a
[ __ ] on your floor okay so now we get
the golden toilet whatever the [ __ ] that
means I have to do this and we find like
chocolate protect protect oh yes what do
I do with all this [ __ ] literally
that's it's funny it's funny
what are we playing today I don't even
know that would say is it what are we
playing today I don't even know what
ever play I'm sorry we're playing I
don't even know I try I try to make a
joke and it failed
what are you till this game from Ken
because Ken steals games from me that's
how it's done okay it says boy cool
which men stole to cookie I am NOT uh-oh
we are playing as a blobfish are we have
a loot wherever looting what am I gonna
become yes
six-pack blobfish oh no we are sucking
them up with our ABS our law our Lord
and Savior blobfish
he's evolving into why me you are the
chosen one
oh god now we need a hundred Jesus what
is happening yes yes yeah hahaha
nightmares thanks
I love nightmares but I don't care what
they say I'm in love with blobfish one
more day why what nightmares are we
gonna get next I can't wait oh it looks
good it looks very promise yes the blob
king will prevail the blob King shall
conquer all I just realized it kind of
looked like old man's balls with noses
oh my god I actually did it holy [ __ ]
what is happening why is it black why is
it black what is this hello oh my oh oh
oh my god what
what I am a cookie know is me I haven't
have arms you can still eat cookies if
you have arms myself is not man that it
has to be the cookie has to be them well
then I don't know oh that was a head and
I click in Steve don't dodge it Steve
it's gonna happen whatever you do stop
there you go stupid Steve have him get
eat what the [ __ ] is English how you
make asplode they're really asking the
tough questions in this game huh yeah
damn it I am stuck ooh well you're not
allowed gotta cover is nude nice but no
I cover his now it looks like something
else censorship it doesn't always work
fix rocket police why fix rocket when
you can be rocket yay
paper or plastic ma'am I will have some
paper please and plastic not both
anybody home uh I would just press my
face against the window what else would
I do
yes what is that is this to life of
chapati ooh ooh yeah ah yeah ah what
make and wish you're not even making any
sense that's not even proper grammar and
why would I just take them all out like
this wish came true
okay kiss deny agreement I agree to eat
nasty foods signed mr. funky no no no no
no oh yes quick your license mister I'll
be this puppy yugioh card it's a fake I
have a fake
Keiko card as my license that's pretty
good Best Buy I love Best Buy next
mission I don't even know right click
what click here to win the game click
here to not win the game
haha no I restarted it No
all right hope you enjoyed this video if
you did go ahead and hit that like
button if you don't I will take off my
shirt your job you made a wise decision
today thank you watching Bruce I really
appreciate it and as always sky awesome
Freddie wasn't even allowed to get close
to right toward why not
we're Freddie no no chica Freddie what
are you doing